CHRISTIAN KURZKE: All right.
Thanks for coming, everyone.
It's a packed room.
So today, what I'm going to
talk about is Android on
Television.
And I don't know how many of you
have actually ever been on
television.
There's a few.
Great.
I mean, people do some really
amazing stuff to get on
television.
And as--
who knows Jeff Foxworthy?
My favorite guys.
Eh, it's not the southern
crowd here.
As he said, you might be a
redneck if you've been on TV
more than five times describing
the sound of a
tornado going over your
neighbor's barn.
Great.
So, fortunately you guys don't
have to describe the sound of
a tornado to get on national
television.
You're developers.
You have much better ways
to get on television.
So let's see how we can get
your apps on television.
So most people, when they hear
about Android, what they think
about is phones.
And I don't know if people--
I don't know, anybody here has
developed apps for phones
before we called them
smartphones?
Back in the days-- yeah,
you remember.
That was not a fun time.
You had a lot of different
operating systems.
You have different programming
languages.
You had different app stores.
I mean just the hassle.
If you had a tic-tac-toe game,
and you wanted to create a
game that runs across all the
different OEMs and all the
different carriers, it
was a nightmare.
You have to write it in Java.
You had to write
it in Symbian.
You had to make deals with all
the different partners.
And believe it or not,
it's the same way
still for set-top boxes.
So if any of you wants to
develop an app today that runs
on TVs, and you target
conventional set-top boxes,
there's a lot of different
frameworks.
There's a lot of different
programming languages.
It's really difficult to get an
app out that just runs on
everybody's television
in the living room.
And smart TVs were really a big
thing this year, if you
have been at the Consumer
Electronics Show in Las Vegas.
Last year everybody was
talking about 3D.
This year, it's like every
manufacturer, you walk into
their booth, they all talk about
their smart television,
and how they are
smart TVs now.
So smart TVs are
really coming.
And I don't know how many of you
actually watch television,
but I just want to remind
you TV is this thing
in the living room.
I know a lot of you have
a TV on the desk.
I mean, I have--
on my desk, I have
four or five TVs.
One of my guys from Canada,
it's his tanning booth.
That's Chris B. For you.
But yeah, I mean, if you think
about it, normal people who
don't come to Google I/O,
they watch television
five hours a day.
And that's a lot
of TV watched.
And the other-- on the flip
side, they don't watch
television for 19 hours a day.
So there's still a lot
of time you can fill
with intelligent apps.
So the goal is to just don't
turn the TV off anymore.
So the good news is we are now
really very successful in
making Android scale from very
small screens from anywhere
from two-inch or three-inch
phones, over tablets, all the
way to the biggest screen
in the house.
So we have launched Google TV
two years ago with an open app
ecosystem, and we've added a
lot of new devices over the
last two years.
And it really gives developers
a platform to create Android
applications that run on
different manufacturer TVs
around the world, and it's easy
to distribute through the
Google Play store.
So I assume you're
all developers.
You know how to create apps.
That is the easiest way for you
to get your apps onto the
television.
Just want to give you a couple
highlights of the
accomplishment.
You probably know
this guy here.
Google TV--
I mean, first of all, Android
is really big in Korea.
And Google TV is very big
in Korea, as well.
So, as a developer, keep
that audience in mind.
We have a deal with the--
I think it's the largest
Korean cable operator.
It's LG Uplus.
And every LG Uplus cable box
rolled out has the Google TV
Android framework on it.
So there's a lot of new
devices coming online.
And around the world, we also
have launched a lot of retail
devices together with
our partners.
So here is just a very
small sampling.
I couldn't really fit all
of them onto the slides.
But on the third floor, you
can have a look at the LG
televisions.
So we have now two generations
of LG televisions, which
integrate the Android
Google TV stack.
We have what we call
buddy boxes.
You connect them to your
existing TVs to turn them into
smart Android TVs.
And so we have launched
a series of
partners with ARM chipsets.
So we have Sony.
We have VIZIO.
We have [? High ?]
Sense.
We have over 10 manufacturers
worldwide who are currently
building Android devices
with Google TV.
So how do you create apps?
And how do you distribute
them?
Let me recap a little bit.
When we talk about TV apps,
we're really looking for
applications that are optimized
for the living room
experience.
A lot of people think about how
can I bring my existing
mobile app to TV?
And it's really about the user
experience, how you make the
user interface intuitive
to be used on a TV.
So this is what a great app
looks like, for example, from
Redbox-Verizon.
It's video on demand.
Everybody likes video
on their television.
So this gives them a great way
to distribute high-quality
video to Google TV users.
And they actually started with
their tablet application.
And they were already very
close to a TV app.
They just added some support
for remote controls.
And I'll explain a little bit
about this more later.
So the first good news for
everyone is sometimes I talk
with people who think that they
need a special SDK for
developing for television.
The good news is really
don't need
anything special or different.
You can use the standard
Android SDK.
And you can just download the
Android eclipse plug-ins.
And you can get started
developing
for Google TV today.
There is a little
bit confusion.
There is an SDK add-on that's
currently in the Google and
the Android SDK servers.
It's really just an emulator.
But I would recommend--
The television is such a
different experience.
The television is very different
use case, compared
to your mobile phone
or your tablet.
You should really experience
the hardware, and have the
hardware in your living
room, and use it.
That's the best way to really
figure out how people interact
with your app.
So if you are serious about
developing for television, by
all means, have the hardware
that you develop on and get a
small set-top box or
a small buddy box.
It's actually the cheapest
Android device
you can buy out there.
It's much less money
than you would have
to spend on a telephone.
So if everything is just
Android, why am I actually up
here on stage?
What are we talking about?
Well, it's the Android SDK,
but there is a small
difference between
a phone and a TV.
And you may remember, the remote
control of your TV is
sort of the most important
thing in the living room.
When you lose your remote
control, you basically have
broken your TV.
I remember when I was growing
up, my parents
didn't have a remote.
I usually have to get off the
couch and walk across the room
and change channels.
So fortunately we've had remotes
for TVs for a very
long time, and they have
come a very long way.
But they're still different
from actually
touching the screen.
And it's subtle things in the
user experience that you
really have to try
out for your app.
The good news is, if you
remember some of the early
Android devices--
so this is the original
Motorola Droid.
They already had a DPAD.
So Android has had support for
DPAD since, I think it was
Version 2, Eclair.
And there has always been ways
to implement focusable
elements and DPAD focus
in Android.
It's just something that a lot
of developers, when they
develop for tablets or touch
devices, they don't spend a
lot of time testing
and optimizing.
So if you develop for TV, keep
in mind the remote control is
really the primary input
mechanism for your users.
Now that you've developed an
app, how do you make sure it
actually shows up in
the Play store?
And there is a lot of,
sometimes, frustration where
people develop an app that
they have tested.
And they have sideloaded
on their
television, and it works.
And then they upload it to Play
Store, and it doesn't
show up on Play Store.
So what you have to keep in
mind is, by default, the
Android Play Store assumes that
your application requires
a touchscreen, simply because
most Android devices up to
today have already
touchscreens.
So you have to-- as a developer,
you know about
features and manifests.
So you have to add a very simple
tag to your manifest to
declare that you have tested
your app without a
touchscreen, and your app is
ready to run on a device that
does not have a touchscreen.
And it's a simple
manifest tag.
You just to declare
the feature
"android.hardware.touchscreen"
is not required.
And if you do that,
your app will show
up in the Play store.
And it will show up
when somebody goes
in from Google TV.
If you don't want to mess with
the XML, it's very simple.
In the editor-- in the manifest
editor-- you can just
select the touchscreen property,
and set it to false.
You can also create applications
that run on touch
and no-touch devices.
I just want to highlight this.
If you declare that you do not
need a touchscreen, that means
you will still work on
a touchscreen device.
So if you want to create
different layouts.
For example, you have a
gesture-based, swipe-based
layout for your application when
it runs on a touchscreen,
then you can have a simplified
and maybe DPAD-navigable UI
for non-touchscreen devices.
And Android gives you mechanisms
to declare layout
files based on different
device capabilities.
And one of them is to
touchscreen property.
So you can declare a
no-touch layout.
So here's an example.
You guys have all use the I/O
Scheduler app all week long.
What we've done is, just for
testing, we loaded it
onto a Google TV.
And you can actually sideload
it to a Google TV, and it
works reasonably well.
This is because the guys who
wrote the I/O Scheduler app
took all the necessary Android
best practices to heart, and
they designed the application
to scale to all different
screen sizes.
And so it scales not only from
a phone to a tablet, it also
scales all the way to
a television size.
So this is an example of an app
that runs, really, on all
Android devices out there.
So let's look at some
of the basics.
So here is a user interface.
You can actually see this
application being demoed out
in our sandbox upstairs
on the third floor.
This is a music app.
It's by Tunein.
They have worked with me over
the last couple of months to
create a really amazing
experience on our new Google
TV devices.
And so this is what
their main--
I want to call it the "hero"
screen-- looks like.
This is cover art for all
the different artists
you can listen to.
And effectively, if you look at
it from a developer's point
of view, there is a number
of focusable
elements on the screen.
If this was a touchscreen, the
interface was very simple.
People would just randomly touch
things on the screen.
Now let's look when you
use this with a DPAD.
Let's assume the focus is on
this blue rectangle element.
And the user presses the DPAD
down key, so the question is
what should happen?
Well, normal users would expect
that the focus just
goes one row down and highlights
this element.
Sometimes, when you didn't test
that, depending on how
you defined the layouts--
how you boxed the XML layouts
inside of each other-- is it
horizontal list views, is it
gallery views, and so on?
You may sometimes end up with
the focus jumping across the
screen to the first element
in the next row down.
Or sometimes the focus may just
go to the next element
down, which literally is all
the way off to the side.
So those are not good
user experiences.
And Android has very simple
mechanisms for you to declare
what is the proper and what
is the expected behavior.
So you can-- this is, again,
standard APIs.
You can use Android
nextFocusDown, nextFocusLeft,
Right, and so on, to explicitly
declare which
elements should get focused
for key down, for
key left, key right.
A lot of developers, when you
just develop for touchscreen
devices, don't necessarily
test this, or don't
necessarily think about
adding this.
And so the Android default focus
handling, it works most
of the time.
But if you want to have a very
high quality application, you
should at least test it.
And whenever Android default
focus handling does not do
what you want it to do, you can
explicitly override the
defaults, and you can declare
it in your files.
Needless to say, things like
swipe gestures, they
theoretically work on TV, but
they're very hard to discover.
And they are sometimes not very
user friendly to use.
So you may want to replace those
with either additional
elements on the screen for next
or previous screen, or
you can also just simplify
your UI.
Most of the time, people try
to put too many things on a
single screen.
And just because you have 60
inches or 80 inches of TV
screen doesn't mean you can put
a whole lot more content
on it than you would
put on a phone.
People sit much further back
from a TV screen, as well.
Another frequently encountered
problem that I would like to
highlight to you--
So if you create an application
that uses the
network, I know a lot of
developers, they check for the
Wi-Fi network being enabled on
the phone, and make decisions
if, for example, high-quality
video streaming is available
only on Wi-Fi.
It's not available when you're
on a data network.
So if you only check for Wi-Fi,
you will see that on
Google TV, where we also have
an ethernet connector, you
will get an error message
that says, oh, there
is no network available.
So you have to make sure to
check connectivity manager not
only TYPE_WIFI, but also
TYPE_ETHERNET.
I forgot to put that
on the slides.
It slipped.
OK, that slipped to
the next line.
So there is a ConnectivityMana
ger.TYPE_ETHERNET.
So you want to check that.
So how do we get our apps
into the Play Store?
So this is just a screenshot
of the current Play
Store on Google TV.
And, as I said earlier, I
frequently see people posting
about, I uploaded my
app to Google Play.
I can't see it in
the Play Store.
What's going on?
Is Google filtering the
apps for television?
Or how can I upload my
app for television?
And, as I explained earlier.
It's filtering based
on features.
So you are familiar with the
Android features in the
manifest file.
If your application requires,
for example, a GPS in order to
work, well, Google TV
does not have a GPS.
So it would not show up.
If you require things like a
camera, again, your app would
not show up.
So make sure you know which
features your application
requires and compare them
with the available
features for Google TV.
The easiest way for you as
a developer to see this--
there is a tool that people
frequently don't know about,
so I want to highlight.
It's the Android Application
Packaging Tool, or AAPT.
And you can use that tool,
simply say "apk dump badging"
and then your APK.
And it will parse
your manifest.
And it will find default
features that your application
uses that maybe you
haven't known.
So one example is if, for
example, your application asks
for the camera permission, we
automatically assume that it
also wants the camera feature.
So once you have verified you
can upload to Play Store,
please include a 16 by
9 feature graphic.
Include a real email address.
Sometimes I go through
the Play Store.
I see people uploading cool
apps, but then I send out an
email to their email address,
and they never answer.
Then I can't give
you feedback.
And let us know on
our Google+ page.
Literally me and my team, we
are always looking for the
next great application that we
can highlight on our Google
Play store.
And we just want to
know about it.
So let us know on Google+
or any of the forums.
It would be nice to find your
application and really give
you some featuring when
your application
meets all the criteria.
So this is how you do basic
applications for Google TV.
Now, let's see what's new.
And how do you really
create awesome apps?
So you may have already seen
the news that we posted, I
think, two days ago.
So as of now, we are really
bringing actively Android
Jelly Bean to Google TV.
I know developers have been
asking about this for a long
time, and it's finally here.
You can see the Android Jelly
Bean prototype TVs upstairs on
the third floor.
We have several new apps that
we're showing that run on
Jelly Bean now.
And let's see what this really
means for developers.
So the first advance is
really the API level.
So we went from Android
Honeycomb, API level 13, to
Android Jelly Bean,
API level 17.
So we have now fully caught
up with the rest
of the Android ecosystem.
And as a developer, you have the
same platform across all
devices now.
We still have the same
high-quality
media delivery APIs.
I will talk about this in just
a second, but we kept all the
different media codecs and all
the streaming technologies
that you're already familiar
with, if you have developed
applications for Google
TV earlier.
We have updated the
Chrome browser.
So we updated the Chrome browser
from Chrome 11 to be
on par with the Google Android
Chrome browser that you know
from your tablets and
from your mobiles.
And right now, it's
running Chrome 28.
And we also have the encrypted
media extensions, and we have
the media streaming
extensions.
I'll explain more about this
in a second, as well.
And we've gotten a lot of
requests, and I'm really
excited to tell you, we now
have NDK for Google TV.
This will hopefully open up
a lot of really cool apps.
So here is one example of
an application that now
runs on Google TV.
And I brought a quick
video clip.
And this is running on our
Google TV in the office.
And we worked with going
with Gameloft.
And it's really beautiful to
see this on a 1080p screen.
So when the Google TV update
rolls out, you will have
access to a lot of new
applications, lot of cool
applications.
So this is just your standard
Asphalt 7 game as you know it
from all your other Android
devices as well.
So what else have we done?
So it's not just standard
Android Jelly Bean.
We have a couple more APIs
that we think are really
useful for people who create
high-quality applications for
the television.
So I just want to highlight
a few of the APIs.
There will be more.
And we will roll out
documentation over the next
couple months.
But of course we have updated
the Android API level, as I
said, the media player,
Chrome, and so on.
So, let's see.
Android APIs.
So a few developers who have
created apps for the current
generation Google TV have
noticed that, with the update
to Jelly Bean, some of the
fundamental Android
permissions, for example,
have changed.
So Android introduced the
additional permissions to, for
example, access your
APN settings.
So we also have a new version
of the Google TV
specific API library.
So if you have an app that runs
on Google TV Honeycomb,
and you want to bring it to
Google TV Jelly Bean, pay
attention to some of
the differences
in the Android platform.
We have skipped from 13 to
17, so it was a big jump.
And we've also updated
the TV libraries.
So when you include the TV
library, what do you get?
You get, for example,
an improved version
of the media player.
So you're hopefully familiar
with the Android media player.
It allows you to play back a
lot of different streaming
formats and a lot of different
video formats.
We have extended the standard
Android media player.
And we have added support,
for example, for
adaptive bitrate playing.
So you can play back adaptive
bitrate streams, which on a TV
is really--
I think it's one of the
core features for TV.
For mobile phones, people tried
to always compress the
video stream as small
as possible.
Playing back a low-resolution
video clip on a 60-inch TV
really looks very not good.
So if you have higher bandwidth,
and people have 10,
20 megabits to their living
room, try to deliver Blu-Ray
quality or as high quality
media as possible.
So with adaptive bitrate
streaming you can do that.
You can also set a
minimum bitrate.
Sometimes it's better to just
show the user no video at all
instead of a pixeled
100 to 200 [?  ?]
[? pixel ?] video.
We introduced what we call
the low-latency mode.
So normal video streaming, it
builds up a buffer in memory
first, for the first 5
or 10 seconds, and
then it starts playback.
With low-latency mode, we start
playback immediately.
And this lets you do things
like cloud gaming.
We are showing upstairs
a sample cloud game.
It's from Ubitus.
And they can play back video
streams and send controller
input back to the backend
in real time.
We also have closed captioning
support.
So as you may be familiar, if
you're in the TV space, it's
very important to enable close
captioning for your viewers.
And we also have quality
of service.
What this means is, it's an
API that allows you to, in
your application, monitor
the streaming quality
at any given time.
So if you are a high-quality
video on demand provider, you
want to make sure you have
analytics in your app to get
information--
what bitrate people can stream,
how many drop frames
there are, and so on.
So with the quality of service
APIs you can do that.
Your app can, at any given time,
monitor the status of
the video stream.
So TV specific APIs.
We think for television it's
very important to support a
large number of streaming
protocols.
We know you have existing
backends.
And it's always a very high
investment for somebody who
has the video backends
and has encoded a
large number of videos.
They don't really want to
re-encode to a new format.
So we make sure we support
a wide range of different
streaming protocols and
media encodings.
We also support virtually all
industry leading DRM solutions.
We know users want the latest
and greatest content on their
television.
We get a lot of requests from
users who want to have
streaming video content of all
their favorite shows and all
their favorite channels.
With Google TV, we have
a trusted video path.
So if you are a content owner,
and you have all those video
assets, you can feel secure
that, when you distribute them
to Google TV, they will be
DRM-protected by our DRM
trusted video path.
We support Widevine and
PlayReady formats.
So if you have existing
backends, so you can just use
those backends.
We also support now--
with the new Chrome browser--
we support HTML5 Encrypted
Media Extensions.
So if you choose to have a HTML
application, and you play
back your video streams through
your Chrome browser,
you can now also-- with the
Encrypted Media Extensions--
you can use DRM in the
Chrome browser.
That opens up a whole new set of
applications for browsers.
So we also have ways to
integrate with your in living
room devices.
And we will publish APIs for
developers to create what we
call media devices.
Just imagine it like a driver
for your other devices in the
living room.
You may have already DVR devices
that currently Google
TV does not fully
integrate with.
If you, as a developer, want
to create drivers for those
devices, we will give you APIs
so that those drivers can be
distributed as Android
APKs and just plug
into the Google TV.
And another exciting
technology.
It's not directly related to our
team here, but the YouTube
team has released Android APIs
for streaming YouTube videos
directly inside of your
Android applications.
And if you're interested in
this, there's actually a code
lab right after this.
It's by my colleague, Chris
B. So you can look for the
YouTube streaming code lab.
He explains how to use the
YouTube APIs to embed YouTube
videos directly in your
Android application.
And that means you don't have
to launch the YouTube player
to play back your app and
effectively lose control of
the user experience.
You can embed it directly
in your application.
And we've worked with some
of the partners.
And they have created some
really amazing applications
that provide a customized user
experience for YouTube content.
So let's look at the Chrome
enhancements in a little bit
more detail.
So we have upgraded to the
latest version of Chrome.
And it's the same Chrome browser
that is available for
all other Android devices.
So, for developers,
this should be a
very familiar platform.
We have also introduced what
we call a Full Screen mode.
When people watch, or interact
with, content on the TV, they
really want to have edge-to-edge
content.
They don't want a browser
status bar
or any of the "Chrome"--
in quotes--
around their application.
So we have this Chromeless
Full Screen mode.
As I mentioned earlier, we
support the Encrypted Media
Extensions.
So that means you can play
back high-quality secure
content using our trusted
video path.
And the media extension
is actually an
interesting use case.
So a lot of people have custom
streaming solutions,
especially if you deliver a
lot of high-quality video.
You want to have control over
your streaming experience.
And we allow you to
customize the
network protocol streaming.
And when you play back a media
from the browser, it will
actually call back
into Android.
And you can implement an entire
protocol handler on the
Android level.
So one example--
what this opens up.
And this is really just to
inspire you to create similar
amazing experiences.
We have worked with Netflix,
and they have brought their
HTML5 experience over
to Google TV.
And this looks just like Netflix
running on any other
living room device.
And that's exactly the point.
For Netflix, it was very easy
to take their existing
HTML-based application and run
it on our Google TV device.
So what we've talked about is
how to bring basic Android
applications to TV.
And then we've talked about how
to bring your TV-optimized
applications to TV.
So hopefully you will be able to
create some really amazing
TV experiences.
And you will be able to bring
your application onto TV.
So I'm really looking forward
to a lot of new apps, and
looking forward to
your apps on TV.
So with that, can I ask my
colleague Andrew-- he is
actually in charge of the
engineering effort for this.
And if you have any questions,
we're taking
questions on stage.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So there is
microphones in the aisle.
Feel free to ask questions
there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Sacha Golden
in Sync Media.
How do you distribute media
steaming extensions on the
Google TV platform?
ANDREW JEON: Your question is
about Android API or web API?
We have two APIs,
both [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: But I understand
that you can deploy your
application, but it's
not application.
Right?
How you publish it?
ANDREW JEON: Well, if you're
talking about Android APIs--
APIs--
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So I think
that the question is, if you
create an application that
uses Encrypted Media
Extensions, how do you bring
those media extensions with
your application?
AUDIENCE: Yes, exactly.
ANDREW JEON: So if you create
a web app which uses a
[INAUDIBLE] extension or
encrypted video extension,
[INAUDIBLE] webpage,
basically.
So people, if you don't know the
URL, you can then directly
go to the webpage.
That's one way [INAUDIBLE]
to discover.
Second way is you can create
a very simple Android
application, which is just
[? a ?] icon or a shortcut.
And then you can [? own ?]
it to market.
And then, once user download it,
and installs the shortcut
app, it's going to be placed
on the All Apps panel, and
user can actually even
move that to a bottom
section, to a highlight.
And when user clicks it, it
is an Android application.
But you can actually send a
URL intent, which will be
grabbed by Chrome browser,
and then direct
user to your web app.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Would you consider
bringing Google TV
to the Nexus Q?
ANDREW JEON: We don't
have a Nexus--
I mean, Nexus was withdrawn last
year, so I don't really
have a comment to make for
that, at this time.
AUDIENCE: I'll keep using
it as a doorstop.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: OK, we have
another question here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm delighted
to see that you're moving up
to Jelly Bean.
On the other hand, I'd really
like to see what the
distribution in the marketplace
looks like and
what your predictions are for
what it will look like over
the next year.
ANDREW JEON: So I think we
have a slide earlier in
[? this ?] presentation.
We have our device partners
planning on learning how many
type of devices which
[INAUDIBLE]
version four, this year.
AUDIENCE: What do I actually
have to design
for right now, though?
ANDREW JEON: Design your app?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Honeycomb right now.
ANDREW JEON: So this summer,
we will have a [INAUDIBLE]
device available in the market,
including the updates
[INAUDIBLE]
devices.
So once [INAUDIBLE] four device
access from the market
can use it.
But if but if you have a serious
plan to develop app
[INAUDIBLE] actually
[INAUDIBLE]
development device.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: We want
to make sure that the
applications are ready when
the devices get updated.
And as Andrew said, we work very
closely with our hardware
partners to make sure the
updates roll out.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
John Blossom.
I'm a Google TV ambassador.
I'm one of the co-leads,
along with Derek Ross.
And we're trying to channel the
right information over to
Google TV enthusiasts, as well
as trying to interface with
the developer community.
One thing that I'm not 100%
clear, in terms of the API
toolkit for Google TV that gets
dropped on top of Jelly
Bean, if you are going--
Is it the case that this kit
will drop on top of any
subsequent Android release?
In other words, is there still a
situation where you have the
kernel bundled with
the Google TV?
Or could you do it separately?
And the second question that
came in from the ambassadors
is where are you on
4K video support?
ANDREW JEON: OK.
Let me try to answer
both of them.
So right now Google TV uses
Android's 10. platform as is.
But, in order to make sure it's
actually working, all the
APIs on the [INAUDIBLE] in line,
whenever new Android
versions on the [? land ?] base
platform comes out, there
will be a release of Google TV
libraries [? config ?] works
with it, always.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So what I hear you saying
there, it's somewhat
decoupled, but not really.
It's really a matter of you
maintaining the libraries now,
in parallel with all the current
Android releases.
Is that the case?
ANDREW JEON: No.
Depends on, let's say our
libraries are using Android
APIs, so it depends
somewhat on APIs.
Between the Android releases,
if there's absolutely no
changes that impacts our
library, there is a chance
that we don't have to update.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
ANDREW JEON: But if there are
changes, so let's say some of
the APIs are deprecated, and
change the packaging from one
to the other, then we have to
update, just to make sure it
compiles correctly.
AUDIENCE: Correct.
So manufacturers and developers
can keep on
overlaying kernel updates, and
just keep on progressing and
not worry about any--
having to synchronize with
toolkit, until it's affected
by underlying changes.
Would there be any reverse
engineering to bring it into
previous Android releases, or is
it strictly moving forward?
ANDREW JEON: It is safe to say
that we always go forward, but
it doesn't mean that we have
to change the API version
every time.
Let's say, for example, an
Android K release comes
online, and we have our API
set, and we don't have any
extra API at the moment.
We could keep the existing APIs,
so the libraries may
have to be re-released,
but the version
same as version two.
There are multiple
cases possible.
We will always minimize
the impact.
AUDIENCE: Do we have any
hardware manufacturers that
are lining up to drop this kit
on top of the tablet as
opposed to a big screen?
ANDREW JEON: We discussed some
of them, but at that moment,
there's no [? accommodate?] to
make her who want to bring
that to tablet--
at the moment.
But I wouldn't say that it will
be impossible [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDREW JEON: The second
question was 4K video.
So 4K support, in terms of the
video playback, 4K support is
completely relying on the
decoder capability, so some of
the SoC partners we are working
with, there are SoCs
capable of playing 4K
video, as you can
see in the TCL case.
So some devices in the market
will be able to, but the
problem is then the display
also needs to be 4K.
It's going to be [INAUDIBLE]
device port device and
actually the SoC [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
kit's ready and
then you have to use.
ANDREW JEON: Right.
For example, our video framework
is independent of
whether the developer tried
to play 4K or not.
For example--
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Andrew,
I think maybe if you're
interested, you can stop by
offline at the sandbox and
check out the TCL 4K TV.
Let's take more questions.
AUDIENCE: Just a
quick question.
You mentioned all the extensions
being available in
Chrome on Google TV.
Are they also available
in web views?
ANDREW JEON: Current version of
the Jelly Bean web view is
different implementation
of a project.
We have a plan, but I can not
actually share any timeline.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So we'll have
to punt over to Chrome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Two quick questions.
So the first one is, is there
any progress with playing with
the actual cable feed, like
overlaying on top of it, or
getting it inside your app on
a different level as a view?
And the second one is are we
going to see any higher-end
devices come out for Google
TV in the near future?
Or are they still going
to stay on the
lower end of the market?
ANDREW JEON: So embedding the
video in your application is
possible today with the version
4, so their TV player
is one of the offering
as a [? probable ?]
TV tool kit, add-on libraries
[? in ?] our application.
And then finally, there's
application which represent
live TV feed, has an API
to resize [INAUDIBLE]
certain size and location, so
that you can place on top.
That's one option.
And in our APIs, lot of APIs but
we don't talk about all of
it, here but once the device
rolled out and
we publish the API.
There's a API called
Media Device View.
And once you instantiate Video
Device View, you can actually
give a TV URL to that, and embed
Video Device View inside
of your location, then you can
actually play live TV video
inside of your application.
That is possible.
The second one was--
AUDIENCE: Higher end devices?
ANDREW JEON: Oh.
Yes, there will be
high-end devices.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
three new features
I'm trying to reconcile.
One was NDK access, but
unfortunately, I think that
that means we'll see an
increase in malicious
applications that might
be able to get
kernel-level access.
And then, two, you have closed
caption support, which I'm
assuming it's going to mean
I've got to do graphic
overlays from say, a GPU on
top of the video stream.
All right?
And then, three, was the
trusted video path.
How exactly are you going to
maintain a trusted video path
in that type of environment?
ANDREW JEON: So in order to
understand this security risk,
you have to understand how
trusted video path is
implemented.
We are actually using hardware
features to protect any
process running on the main
memory and main CPU to be able
to access certain memory zone.
So no matter where the device
is rooted, we don't
[INAUDIBLE].
But even in the case of rooting,
or in any malicious
code, taking over root access,
those projects will not have
access to video data.
AUDIENCE: So you're working
with the chip-level
manufactures in order
to implement that?
We had was quite tough
or basis thank you
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: So I think
we're actually running a
little bit over our time, but
ANDREW JEON: Two
more questions?
[INAUDIBLE]
outside.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Well, I think
it's best is if we take
questions outside.
Just find us outside.
We need to clear the room for
the next presentation.
ANDREW JEON: Thanks a lot.
CHRISTIAN KURZKE: Thank
you very much.